e40 is on the album
yup who else is on the album nobody that
you can know right now
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is two weeks away yeah
give me one
too short two short and e40 yep
they're on the same song obviously they
have to be right
bro you an illuminati get out bro take
this [ __ ]
out of here bro they're all the same
record right hey if you had too short
and e40 on september you knew that
already
it's respectful yeah they on the same
song damn that [ __ ] guy is there's like
some berries [ __ ] yeah it's a berry [ __ ]
hmm
and 21 savage obviously i mean you're
gonna even though the song has been out
for a year and a half you've got to
throw it at the end right
yeah it's going to be a great track
you're going to get that goal that's
what show going on there that what
that's a
little little bonus little tracker i was
going to say like all the songs you've
been dropping because you've been
dropping a lot of singles right
um over the last couple years are you
just going to throw them all on this
project just to kind of
just just to get to run the numbers up
no
you french montana did that [ __ ] nah
ain't french montana
hey he went platinum in a day though
that's hard as [ __ ] too but there was
like five-year-old songs on there
yeah i'm not gonna do that i mean i mean
i mean i can't it's just like but i've
been waiting so long for me to drop an
album like he was dropping albums and
[ __ ] before like it's my first album
it's so crazy to think that this is your
first album i know
and i've been in the game for like four
years is there a reason why
because i you know the ybn uh tape came
out and i just had expected
your [ __ ] to be right after yeah was
that the plan originally
i mean it was but then i was like all
right i'ma let everybody else do that
[ __ ]
and i just stepped back from it because
i i knew i had a lot of people in my
background to do their [ __ ]
to make this young [ __ ] a whole nother
level and they proved to me that they
could do it and um
yeah i just really sat back for a minute
like i had to get right with a lot of
stuff that was in my mind a lot of real
life things and uh i had to get my
mentality straight again
so after that like i was like [ __ ] it
let's
push this [ __ ] let's drop music let's go
crazy with this [ __ ] and i took another
year off
and now [ __ ] i'm back like i was i was
dropping music the whole
2019 damn there but it was like just
youtube world star music like quick
songs
like stuff i put it on instagram and
stay up there just like quick songs like
i'm stopping
yeah and i was 2019 so